[Music]
okay so desean watson's case had a lot
of back and forth
publicly from the lawyers involved and
that was uh early on then everything got
quiet and it got quiet because they were
talking about a potential settlement
then the potential settlement fell apart
on the issue of whether to what extent
the settlement amounts and other facts
would be regarded as confidential there
was a dust up then
and then it got quiet again
and it's been very quiet up until the
past few days which makes me think that
there's still a chance the dam will
break there's still a chance that one
side or the other is going to bend on
the issue of confidentiality or they can
find a compromise on the issue of
confidentiality out of the blue last
week tony busby who represents the 22
women who have sued desean watson for
misconduct during massage therapy
sessions buzzby came out and said
there isn't a settlement and there isn't
going to be one anytime soon
now
i
my read on it
based on the time i spent practicing law
and my knowledge and understanding and
following of this case and and the
unique personality that is tony busby
i think he's feeling some heat
from his clients
to get these wrapped up because they
don't want to have to give depositions
they don't want this to hang around
anymore if my hunch is true that they
have a general idea of what the
settlement amounts will be and it got
hung up on whether or not it was going
to be confidential you've got people who
are thinking what's the holdup why can't
we get this done this is just a
paperwork i agreed on the money why
can't we get this done yeah yeah right
if we have if we have a rough
understanding on the money why is my
money being held up i'm ready to move on
from this the justice that i'm seeking
through the civil justice system is the
payment of money and i'm satisfied with
this this gives me the justice that i
think i deserve why isn't it done
and and i feel like that statement from
busby
would just an effort to rattle the cage
a little bit on rusty harden who
represents desean watson to maybe get
somebody to blank somebody to bend
somebody to do something so they can
wrap these cases up yeah i wouldn't
disagree with that i mean first off i
would think like you know it's like matt
lefleur told jordan love like tony
busby's got to be probably preparing for
trial no matter what right that's going
to be the tough thing to get ready for
and it's
yeah adds to playing hardball and acting
like you know he's they're not ready or
the deal's not ready yet whatever that
may be posturing um but i will say this
like you know the the quote we have at
the bottom to me is like the most
shocking thing of this so far
with with the nfl
yet to interview deshaun watson i don't
am i crazy to think that
why not what's taking so long why hasn't
that happened yet you know to get teams
answers and get the ball rolling on the
availability or in availability of
desean watson mike
in availability is a sims ism first of
all which gives us one for this monday
you did flip coin earlier and you
corrected yourself before it could lock
in you you didn't take your hand off the
checker so that one doesn't count this
one availability does yes um
i i know what the nfl would say about
this and you're referring to rusty
harden's comment because he confirmed
that settlement talks currently aren't
happening but he also told i think it's
kprc in houston apologies if i got the
letters out of order kprc was told by
hardin that the nfl's yet to interview
watson the nfl would say and they've
said in the past
we wait until the end we wait until
we've talked to everyone else before we
talk to the accused and that's generally
a good approach when it comes to
investigating situations like this
however there are differences when it
comes to deshaun watts and first of all
they can talk to him as many times as
they want it's not one shot
you can talk to him and you can talk to
him again later if you need to and to
the extent that there is
a preliminary process premised on
deciding whether or not to put desean
watson on paid leave
the preliminary investigation that they
do to come to that conclusion you would
assume yes that would include talking to
deshaun watson the standard is very is
very broad
without criminal charges he could still
be placed on paid leave if the
commissioner believes he may have
committed
the kind of misconduct
that falls into certain specific
categories and this conduct if it's if
it's true if that he did it it falls
into the category so you interview him
you come away from the interview with a
belief he's telling the truth he's not
telling the truth which one is it i feel
like that's a critical component to
making a responsible decision on whether
or not he should be paid on put on paid
leave and as i've said recently chris
they owe it to him the texans and anyone
who would want to trade for him
to come to that conclusion and let
everybody know right
right don't put people in limbo
don't don't make anyone have to guess
complete your preliminary investigation
talk to watson and decide yes or no up
or down paid leave or no paid leave
and and uh
otherwise it's an incomplete
investigation
that you're relying upon to to make your
decision as to whether or not he's going
to be put on paid leave so yeah i think
they should be talking to right okay now
so they can decide whether or not to put
him on paid leave that i mean that's
that's what jumped out to me i mean
again i'm no lawyer i have no history in
that but i mean i'm glad to hear you say
the same thing because yeah that that's
as a fan ex quarterback whatever i mean
guy that got friends in the nfl yeah i
think there's a lot of people that are
their lives are being affected a little
bit here by the desean watson situation
and yeah it's also good for the shield
to settle this in some sort of capacity
to give everybody you know the direction
this is going or whatever i mean that's
right now i just yeah i'm i was
surprised by that that that really
jumped out to me and i don't know where
this is gonna go mike and i don't know
how your gut feels about maybe something
getting done here before training camp
starts
here's my cynical view yeah my cynical
view is that the nfl intentionally is
creating ambiguity
in the hopes that the cases settle
because if the cases settle
the nfl has no decision to make at all
other than
what unpaid suspension if any will be
imposed against desean watson you never
have to make the paid leave decision if
the case is settled because the case is
settled there's no prosecution there's
nothing
there
that would justify him being placed on
paid leave you just decide whether or
not you you suspend him the way you
suspended ben roethlisberger similar
similar reasoning for suspending
roethlisberger would apply to watson but
i think maybe the nfl is being
deliberately vague here
just as a way to give both sides and
specifically watson an incentive to
resolve the case
and just move on that makes sense so uh
they got six weeks to figure it out
before the start of camp it was last
week nick casario the gm of the texans
said as as we get closer to camp we'll
make a good decision there aren't many
decisions to make trade him or keep him
that's the decision they need to make
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports